[Musique]
votre intention de demander un
dessinateur de venir s'exprimer en
public
la plupart du temps on dessine parce
qu'on a un peu du mal à parler
c'était mon cas j'étais un enfant
extrêmement timide qui parlait très peu
et que certains même pensé
penser on pensait que j'étais autistes
j'ai grandi je suis toujours aussi
timide je parle toujours très peu
aujourd'hui les gens pensent plutôt que
je suis méchant c'est pas grave comme ça
c'est pratique les gens n'osent pas trop
emprunté de l'argent et j'ai donc
organiser ma vie autour de ce
tempérament d'abord j'ai épousé une
femme qui parle beaucoup comme ça ça
compense et puis je me suis mis à une
forme d'expression alternative qui me
permet de combler le manque de parole je
me suis mis au dessin et je suis devenu
progressivement après avoir été un muet
amateur je suis devenu un muet
professionnelle en devenant dessinateur
de presse est ce que je peux partager
avec vous ce soir c'est cette manière
dont effectivement le dessin peut être
une sorte de béquille communicationnel
qui permet de dire des choses que la
parole parfois a du mal à exprimer pour
différentes raisons
une première raison à laquelle je peux
penser qui explique certaines choses
sont quasiment indicible
c'est l'effroi en général quand vous
êtes choqué par une situation et qu'on
vous demande de me donner votre
sentiment vous dit
les mots me manquent les mots sont
faibles alors le dessin peut
effectivement venir à la rescousse une
chose totalement effroyable c'est la
mort des enfants
il ya quelques années il y avait une
poupée qui étaient fabriqués en chine
qui s'appelait polly pocket qui étaient
fabriqués avec un défaut il y avait
quelques pièces je crois que c'était les
yeux ou je ne sais plus quel quels
éléments qui se détachaient et les
enfants jouaient à 20 ans jouant à
vallet ces pièces et commençait à
étouffer
alors le dessinateur il essaie de mettre
un peu de pudeur dans cette situation et
d'exprimer ce qui s'est passé avec très
peu de mots je dessine la poupée telle
qu'elle est dans l'imagerie commercial
sur son emballage
et puis comme on l'a retiré du marché je
la fait s'estomper progressivement et à
force de la voir disparaître
on croit deviner une autre forme qui
relève du pictogramme que l'on voit sur
les bouteilles de poison et là on
s'aperçoit effectivement que ça évoque
plutôt la mort
autre situation extrêmement compliquée à
exprimer ce sont les attentats qui donne
un sentiment évidemment de l'extrême
injustice
ce dessin par exemple qui a été fait le
jour d'un attentat à ouagadougou et qui
a été mis sur les réseaux sociaux a fait
l'objet de plusieurs commentaires et le
tout premier commentaire qui a été fait
sur facebook je crois c'est est ce
dessin dit plus que mille mots donc
c'est ce qu'on essaie de partager
ensemble ce soir il ya des moments où on
est étranglée par l'émotion il faut
essayer d'utiliser d'autres formes
d'expression parfois lorsqu'il ya des
attentats on est amené à exprimer
l'émotion mais il ya aussi d'autres
choses qu'il faut exprimer des débats
parallèles qui sont pas très facile à
développer sous forme de parole au
moment du deuil
par exemple si on se souvient le 11
septembre tout le monde a en mémoire les
deux tours jumelles en train de brûler
et est apparu à ce moment là un
phénomène qui était un phénomène de
stigmatisation d'une population à qui on
attribue et certaines caractéristiques
physiques qui ont montré certaines
personnes du doigt en disant ah voilà
cette communauté a tendance à se réjouir
dans son entièreté de cette situation
alors le dessinateur qu'est ce qu'il
essaie de faire à un moment donné où on
veut pas faire trop de moralisme donc on
veut pas faire trop de grands discours
et pc c'est pas le moment non plus de
parler beaucoup alors au mais cette
image dans des yeux dans des regards de
plusieurs personnes
en l'espèce ce sont des enfants et on
voit bien que ces enfants qui ont les
caractéristiques physiques un peu
stigmatiser notamment la jeune fille
voilée lorsqu'ils regardent l'attentât
du 11 septembre ne sont pas du tout en
train de se réjouir mais sort évidemment
dramatiquement touchés comme la plupart
des gens une autre raison qui explique
que parfois la parole est insuffisante
et qu'on a du mal à expliquer certaines
situations c'est la complexité des
choses lorsque vous expliquer quelque
chose à quelqu'un qui n'a pas l'air de
comprendre vous le regardez puis vous
lui dites mais il faut que je te fasse
un dessin et ben oui c'est pas seulement
une expression des fois c'est utile de
faire un dessin
et comme dessinateur de presse sont nous
demandent par exemple d'illustrer des
concepts économiques un peu compliqué et
moi on m'avait demandé de faire un
dessin sur la microfinance ce qui n'est
pas un sujet très réjouissant parce
qu'on imagine en général que tous les
dessins sont censés être humoristique
alors j'utilise un ressort qui est celui
que l'on trouve aussi bien dans les
fables européenne que dans les contes
africains c'est représenter les
personnages les protagonistes grâce à
des animaux et puisqu'on parle de
finances je me demande en finance quel
est l'animal qui représente la
négativité la méchanceté c'est
évidemment le requin les fameux requins
de la finance alors la pauvreté dans mon
dessin va être incarnée par un vilain
requins et puisque je suis dans l'eau je
suis obligé de filer la métaphore est
donc les opérateurs économiques qui vont
bénéficier de la microfinance je vais
les représenter sous forme de poisson
mais la microfinance s'adresse comme son
nom l'indiqué à des micro entrepreneurs
des micros acteurs et donc là on se dit
ce pauvre poissons ils feraient mieux de
s'éloigner parce qu'il peut pas faire le
poids face à la pauvreté
sauf que le concept de la microfinance
et de donner des toutes petites sommes à
des tout petits acteurs mais en nombre
assez important
alors on aide plusieurs poissons puis un
nombre de plus en plus important de
poissons qui finissent grâce à la micro
finance par représenter une masse
susceptibles de faire le poids face à la
pauvreté
une autre raison qui peut expliquer
parfois que les choses sont difficiles à
dire c'est tout simplement que les
choses sont parfois interdite à exprimer
il y as parfois tout simplement une
véritable confiscation de la parole ici
dans le dessin vous voyez ce code que
vous connaissez tous notamment si vous
lisez les bandes dessinées le fait de
représenter la parole par une bulle et
là on voit effectivement que la parole
est au sens premier du terme confie
et par un militaire parfois la censure
n'est pas absolue il ya une certaine
forme de liberté d'expression mais il ya
certaines choses qui sont un peu
difficile à dire au risque soit d'être
accusés de procès d'intention soient
parfois même de subir un procès par
exemple pour offense au chef de l'état
il ya une situation comme observateur
journalistique que j'ai vu dans
plusieurs pays notamment la côte
d'ivoire notamment le soudan avant la
scission c'est que parfois les pays sont
divisés à cause d'une crise à cause d'un
ça peut être une guerre civile ça peut
être une rébellion qui occupe une partie
du territoire et tous les hommes
politiques les différents camps ont tous
le mot paix à la bouche
pis en anglais et donc ce dessin je peux
par exemple l'appliquer au cas de la
république démocratique du congo à
l'époque du rebelle laurent nkunda et on
voit ces deux personnages qui se donnent
bonne conscience en parlant de paix
alors qu on sait qu en réalité dans leur
comportement ils ne font qu'alimenter la
guerre alors moi je regarde ces deux
messieurs qui parlent de paix qui parle
beaucoup de paie de plus en plus de paix
et à force de parler de paix moi je
crois deviner un autre mot aussi en
anglais qui se dessine est derrière les
discours de paix se cache en fait un
comportement de guerre war et là vous
voyez que le dessin il a bien sûr comme
première vocation à être un contenant de
mots mais il peut devenir aussi une
forme à laquelle on va faire dira
peut-être autre chose et dans des
domaines très différents
ça c'est un dessin sur le racisme
à un moment il n'y a pas très longtemps
ou en france certaines personnes
voulaient nuancer la gravité de
certaines insultes racistes comme
ou
et ce dessin montre que à la
fois la bulle est un contenant de mots
racistes et en même temps une forme où
on voit se dessiner un monstre avec des
dents très agressif le message étant
donc que la parole raciste est
pratiquement aussi grave aussi violente
que l'agression physique d'autres cas
aussi peuvent utiliser cette même
technique
nous avons ici deux personnages qui
représentent une négociation sociale
on a un ouvrier et un patron qui
officiellement sont là pour être
constructif mais il suffit de
représenter leur bulle sous une forme
particulière pour comprendre qui sont
plutôt dans une logique de combat de
boxe
une autre raison pour laquelle certaines
choses sont difficiles à dire c'est
qu'il y a parfois tout simplement des
blocages au niveau du langage pour des
questions d'alphabétisation insuffisante
lorsqu'on travaille sur des supports
écrits ou tout simplement parce que les
langues qui se confrontent ne sont pas
les mêmes et tous les acteurs qui
cherchent à communiquer ne parlent pas
la même langue
c'est une chose intéressante de
considérer alors que le dessin est
pratiquement une langue universelle et
ça les personnes qui s'occupent de la
communication de la sensibilisation
l'ont bien compris
voici par exemple une image qui
sensibilise aux bons usages de l'eau à
la bonne pratique en matière d'hygiène
ce n'est pas un dessin que j'ai fait
c'est pas un dessin de presse mais c'est
un dessin que j'ai photographié dans un
camp de réfugiés du darfour où se
croisait beaucoup de langues différentes
si on regarde simplement les langues
internationales il y avait les darfouri
qui parlaient plutôt l'arabe il y avait
les tchadiens qui s'occupait d'eux
qu'ils parlaient plutôt français les ong
parlait anglais allemand et puis il y
avait toutes les langues locales que
l'on peut imaginer
et donc sur un support écrit placardées
aux murs par exemple
il était tout à fait utile de faire un
dessin sans aucune parole pour qu'il
puisse être compris par tout le monde
ce n'est pas un dessin de presse mais le
dessin de presse peut utiliser la même
technique
j'ai longtemps travaillé pour un organe
de presse italien qui publiait
systématiquement ses contenus en trois
langues italien anglais et français
on peut traduire un dessin mais moi
j'étais plutôt tentiez de faire un
dessin sans aucun mot et un jour on m'a
demandé de traiter la question de
l'après kadhafi quelques mois après
kadhafi
on sentait que les islamistes radicaux
risque est en tout cas été en situation
de prendre le pouvoir
alors moi je commence par dessiner
kadhafi et puis moi je suis à l'esprit
très simple et très bête
donc comme on a dit qu'on a renversé
kadhafi moi j'ai renversé physiquement
kadhafi et kadhafi prend la forme lorsqu
on le retourne d'un barbus enturbannés
donc là on pourrait faire à partir de ce
dessin tout un long article de plusieurs
pages pour expliquer la situation mais
le dessin essai de résumer cela parfois
aussi il ya des choses qui sont
difficiles à dire parce qu'elles font
l'objet d'une hypersensibilité ehs on
constate depuis quelques années que la
question religieuse par exemple devient
de plus en plus difficile à aborder de
façon en tout cas assez indépendante et
on se rappelle évidemment la faire les
affaires même des caricatures de mahomet
ce qui veut dire que dans ce cas là le
dessin n'est pas toujours la meilleure
manière d'apaiser les esprits
sauf à utiliser le dessin de façon un
peu contournée et de façon un peu
ludique et voici par exemple sur la
représentation de mahomet un dessin qui
joue sur la complicité qui peut exister
entre un lecteur et le dessinateur
récurrent dans un journal et là on
invite le lecteur à caricaturer lui-même
le prophète à la manière de charlie
hebdo
je veux pas m'arrêter là parce que sinon
on va pas me payer le dessin on va dire
que j'ai ri
donc je vais quand même dessiné
peut-être d'une certaine façon mahomet
mais de façon ludique
c'est à dire comme un jeu et là on voit
effectivement que si les gens relie les
points
ils vont tomber exactement sur le fameux
mahomet dessinée dans charlie hebdo et
qui avait fait l'objet de plusieurs
couvertures notamment après l'attentât
de charlie hebdo
ce qui est important c'est de faire
passer des messages et je pense que ce
dessin fait passer plusieurs messages
c'est un message aux jihadistes ça monte
qui nous fatigue un petit peu qui
devrait pas nous interdire de dessiner
mahomet mais on essaie de jouer un peu à
cache cache avec eux c'est un dessin
peut être aussi qui se moque aussi des
dessinateurs parce qu'on sente le
dessinateur il a un peu peur de dessiner
mahomet il veut s'en remettre aux
lecteurs et repousser la responsabilité
loin de lui et les dessinateurs n'ont
pas toujours beaucoup d'autodérision
donc ça c'est important
et puis je pense que le message le plus
important c'est de dire à chaque
individu qui lit le journal dans lequel
est paru cette caricature que à la
question ai-je le droit de dessiner
mahomet chacun a le droit d'avoir une
réponse différente
le dessinateur n'est pas là pour imposer
une vérité absolue donc à chacun de
décider s'il va rejoindre les points
pour représenter mahomet toutes les
religions évidemment peuvent faire
l'objet de dessin là on a un dessin qui
représente plutôt une religion
chrétienne
l'idée encore une fois n'est pas
d'insulter gratuitement ou de faire un
dessin juste pour provoquer quelqu'un
mais de faire passer un message le
message qui passait
lorsque ce dessin est parue c'était que
certains groupes d'obédience chrétienne
utilisent plutôt le nom de jésus pour
faire du business
je vous laisse imaginer de quelle genre
de groupe on peut parler mais donc on à
la confrontation entre une image qui est
de l'ordre de l'iconographie religieuse
avec les mains transpercé avec la lore
hall de jésus et puis en même temps une
imagerie qui relève du marketing qui
relève du graphisme qui fait penser à
une certaine marque de soda et puis
évidemment ce qui est difficile à dire
aussi c'est peut-être ce qui parfois
heurte la pudeur on a parlé de timidité
au début on peut parler aussi de la
pudeur et donc le dessin peut parfois
aussi expliquer certaines situations
d'ordre sentimental
les relations entre les gens voilà un
dessin qui au premier regard est
extrêmement positif on voit un homme qui
offre un bouquet à une femme
la situation est parfaite sauf que on a
vu qu'à des codifications dans le dessin
et il ya une chose très importante dans
les dessins c'est le cadrage
si on élargit le cadrage on commence à
distinguer quelque chose de bizarre à
l'arrière de la femme
il semble manquer quelque chose au
niveau de son pagne et d'ailleurs on
remarque que ce qui est à l'intérieur du
bouquet ressemble étrangement à ce pagne
là et on comprend le fond de la sphère
en découvrant ce qui se cache derrière
le dos de l'homme qui manifestement
n'était pas si amoureux au point
d'acheter des fleurs il a préféré
découper le pagne pour séduire la femme
à moindre frais
vous voyez déjà c'était le cas aussi
dans le dessin sur la république
démocratique du congo
que dire des choses indicibles c'est
aussi parfois dire l'hypocrisie dire ce
qui n'est pas dit l'époux crise' peut
évidemment exister dans les relations
amoureuses
on voit ici un trio assez classique
tu vois qu'il ya des gens qui se
reconnaissent on a une femme
manifestement délaissé triste qui
regarde celui qu'on peut imaginer si on
fait une comparaison des tranches d'âge
on peut imaginer que c'est son mari au
milieu et l on exprime sa pensée par un
coeur un peu fissurée lui manifestement
son attention est attirée ailleurs il a
aussi un coeur mais qui a une autre
nature et la jeune fille a également un
coeur d'une autre nature
donc là on dit ce que les gens ne disent
pas pas parce que c'est interdit ou trop
sensible mais parce qu'ils n'ont pas
envie de le dire parce qu'à une forme
d'hypocrisie
et puis évidemment si on parle de des
relations intimes et de la difficulté
d'exprimer certaines choses
on pense évidemment à la sexualité qui
est en afrique pour le dessinateur de
presse je crois le tabou majeur
on s'aperçoit que quand un dessinateur
dessine quelque chose à caractère un peu
sexuelle il provoque tout de suite une
réaction outrée lui-même semble paniquer
alors il essaie de finir son dessin
rapidement pour le maquiller et ça
devient autre chose
et c'est un peu curieux parce qu'on
imagine que normalement à militaire avec
une kalach est plus dangereux qu'un
dessin de pénis mais ce n'est pas
toujours le cas
et puis pour terminer toujours sûr c'est
sur ces notions une autre manière
d'exprimer des choses qui ne sont pas
dit de façon graphique
voilà encore une situation sentimentale
avec un couple situation qui a l'air de
se dérouler de façon tout à fait
positive on voit que l'homme a dessiné
un coeur sur le sol donc il a
manifestement de très bonnes intentions
et là on peut avoir une autre manière de
voir les pensées cacher les quelles
pensées sont elles mêmes
un souhait de ces personnes chacun se
demande est ce que tu souhaites ce que
je souhaite est ce que tu désires ce que
je désire et c'est par la projection des
ombres des personnages sur le mur on va
comprendre ce que chacun a en tête la
femme lorsqu on projette son ombre sur
le mur on voit une femme avec un gros
ventre
donc on imagine qu'elle souhaite que
cette relation aboutisse à quelque chose
de durable qui permettra éventuellement
d'amener une grossesse des enfants une
progéniture
est ce que c'est la chose à laquelle
l'homme pense je vous laisse des
chiffres et je vous laisse des chiffres
sur pied
voilà comment le dessin peut arriver à
dire certaines choses qui sont
interdites à dire des choses qu'on a du
mal à dire parce qu'on a trop d'émotions
et voilà comment le dessin finalement
transforme un enfant très timide dans
conférencier un peu bavard merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]